how's it going everybody it's Warren
today we have major she-hulk news we
have a casting call for she-hulk we have
a working title for the series as well
and of course the report that Marvel
Studios wants Alison Brie to play
she-hulk
and not to mention the news that she
Hulk is set to be a new Avenger in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and I'll break
down every single thing that you need to
know about the she-hulk Disney Plus
Series coming soon in this video be sure
to subscribe with notifications turned
on I'm giving away an Xbox one or ps4
winners choice at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers be sure to comment
below and hit that like button so a lot
of exciting things today community star
Alison Brie is at the very top of
Marvel's list to play Jennifer Walters
aka she-hulk
yesterday Daniel Richmond aka Daniel RPK
reported on his patreon that Marvel
Studios is searching for an Alison Brie
type to be cast in their upcoming she
hoped Disney Plus series with Alison
Brie at the very top of their list
obviously they want an Alison Brie type
Alison Brie would be at the top of their
list in the comics Jennifer Walters is
Bruce Banner / the Hulk's cousin and she
gets into an accident and in order to
save her life Bruce Banner does a blood
transfusion with her and it does work it
saves her life but it also turns her
into a female version of the Hulk
hence she-hulk now as far as Alison Brie
playing Jennifer Walters / she-hulk
that is an absolutely fantastic choice
she is an amazing actress on community
and Mad Men an actress that many people
would enjoy to see play Jennifer Walters
but here's the really big news behind
the casting for she-hulk the casting
call for she-hulk seeks a 26 to 34 year
old actress of any race the heroes
backstory is identical to that of the
comics a mild-mannered lawyer
Jennifer waters gained superpowers after
receiving a blood transfusion from her
cousin Bruce Banner
but the casting call goes on to mention
that she Hulk is a future member of the
Avengers now we know that Disney Plus is
going to tie into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that has already been confirmed
however she-hulk would be the first
character to jump from a Disney Plus
show to the MCU
all of the other future and New Avengers
have gone from movies to Disney Plus
shows one division Loki
Falkon in the Winter Soldier etc and
this new report seemingly confirms the
first a new Avenger because we're not
really sure who the new Avengers are
going to be we have a pretty good idea
but nothing is really confirmed yet
so the first member of our new Avengers
team is Jennifer Walters aka
she-hulk and it seems like there's a
fairly good chance if everything works
out schedule wise that Alison Brie will
be playing she-hulk now recently the
she-hulk series was also given the
working title Libra Libra comes from the
astrological signs which it's symbol is
scales ain't no to justice scales and
Jennifer Walters his day job as a
defense lawyer she-hulk is going to
begin filming this summer in Atlanta so
casting is going to have to be completed
very soon so soon we'll learn a lot more
but let me know what you think about
this casting choice and the comments
down below don't forget to like this
video and subscribe when notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
forth